democrats and republicans squaring off  over what to do about the historic level  of student debt in our country americans  have racked up more than 1.7 trillion  dollars in student loans spread across  some 43 million borrowers second only to  home mortgages as the largest category  of debt in the u.s  president biden has already forgiven  billions in student loan debt and has  hinted that more action may be on the  horizon but not everyone agrees with  that move canceling student debt would  also be grossly unfair  to the americans who worked hard for  years to pay off their loans  republicans agree rising costs are a  problem but have introduced legislation  blocking the president from forgiving  student loans saying taxpayers shouldn't  be on the hook  whether the president does have the  authority has sparked fierce debate as  well the education department has yet to  come to a conclusion